doctor found you great to have you with
us thank you very much I know that these
have been very long days and we're glad
to have you with us on this Friday
evening I'd like to start with the
question of these models which are now
getting a lot of pushback in terms of
their reliability when the numbers have
swung you know 33 percent in just a
couple of days what do you say to Andy
McCarthy who wrote that piece well I
mean there's a certain validity to it I
have been and still am and will always
be somewhat reserved and skeptical about
models because models are only as good
as the assumptions that you put into the
model and those assumptions that start
off when you don't have very much data
at all or the data that you have is
uncertain that you put these assumptions
in and you get these wide ranges of
calculations of what might happen you
know a hundred thousand to two hundred
and forty thousand deaths but then as
you start to accumulate data data that's
real data are likely being influenced
heavily by the mitigation programs that
you put into physical separations that
when real data comes in then data in my
mind always Trump's any model and you
have to modify the model and the
assumptions as you get data in so I have
no problem with people who are critical
of modeling because modeling is
inherently an imperfect science so I
don't really have any quibbling with
that and you just got to make sure as
you collect real data you rely more on
the data than you do on a model yeah
sure I mean all of that makes a lot of
sense but I think one of the problems is
that those models were what we were used
to shut down the United States economy
the fear that those numbers when we
looked at a hundred thousand to two
hundred and forty thousand people and
that was I should point out including
mitigation and social distancing that
was with that factored in so that number
has dropped by thirty three percent so I
guess you know what what kind of model
is so far off that it leads us to
policymaking decisions
that now are having such dire
consequences yeah well first I think
it's
to point out that it isn't the model or
the result of the model that really led
to the decision to have such strong
mitigation programs such as physical
separation you don't even have to look
at any model just take a look at what
happened in China take a look at what
happened in northern Italy how the
hospitals were completely overrun and
the draconian methods that had to be
taken in China to turn down their their
outbreak so I mean if I never saw a
result of a model that alone would
clearly indicate that something rather
significant needed to be done to prevent
the spread so I mean again getting back
to models and and I never argue with
anybody that has a problem with the
model I inherently have problems with
models yeah
you know I should point out that
obviously it's the it's it's very
everyone is very glad that these numbers
are so much further south than what was
anticipated I mean that's a good story
that that's good news and obviously for
every one of those families that is
losing any of the seventeen sixteen
seventeen thousand people who have
passed away and I should also point out
people who are currently struggling with
this really vicious virus want these
precautions to be taken and I and I
think that you know obviously we need to
be very clear about that but just
looking across the country and when you
talk about what happened in Italy I
think that was one of the biggest fears
in this country that people would go
without a ventilator that people would
go without a bed an ICU unit and it
looks now that we have built a lot of
these facilities that thank God
are never going to be used is it true
that no one has gone without an ICU bed
or a ventilator who needed one in this
country yeah to my knowledge that is a
correct statement I'm again i I can't
his great absolutely guarantee but we we
would hear about it I can be absolutely
certain if that were the case but I
think you just said something that is a
correct statement so let's talk a little
bit about reopening the economy you
heard the president say today
in the briefing that this would be the
toughest decision of his life and
certainly of his presidency to this
point because if it backfires if this
thing starts spreading again like
wildfire of course all the fingers will
be pointed towards him the ultimate
decision-maker in this process what are
your thoughts on when it's going to be
safe to go back and what measures will
you be looking at to advise him on that
well you know I I think people need to
understand that the the issue of going
back to essentially reopening the
country which is a terminology that
people sometimes use if you consider the
physical separation in many respects has
shut down so many things I think
reopening it is not going to be like a
light switch that you switch on or off
because if you look at throughout the
country it's a large country and the
outbreaks are really quite different
depending upon where you are new york
new jersey area is very different from
now what we've seen in washington state
and in california in which there was the
threat of a real big spike but it really
didn't occur and it's at that low level
new orleans in some respects was very
much like New York and Detroit also so
if you're going to essentially make the
first steps of trying to gradually open
up the country and hence the economy
there are a lot of parameters first of
all you got to take a look at where the
country as a whole and individual
components of the country like New York
now New York right now interestingly has
had as we predicted essentially the
worst week imaginable every day was more
deaths than the previous day but the
issue is that the deaths lag behind
about two weeks or two and a half weeks
of what feeds into the outbreak named
the number of new cases that lead to
hospitalization that lead to intensive
care that lead to death so although this
was a bad week we're starting to see a
plateauing and a turning around of the
curve in New York if that steeply goes
down and the way we predicted we'll once
you get over that hump then that's
really good news from the standpoint of
being able to
take a look now at New York and how we
could start maybe getting back to some
form of normality it's a little bit
different if you're dealing in some of
the Midwest or mountain states which
don't have those big spikes so the
parameters are we've got to look on it
literally on a day and day by day week
by week basis about what's going on in
various parts of the country because
it's not going to be uni-dimensional
that the whole country is on and the
whole country it's off it's just not
going to be that okay just give me an
example like what can you foresee and
I'm not gonna hold you to this date but
we've talked about May first so let's
just say on the day that you start to
open some things up what what do you
foresee that looking like I mean what
sort of things would start the wheels
turning first what would be the sable
things to the first thing well the safe
that thinks open is you look at what is
essential to the functioning of the
community you know besides health care
providers besides emergency responders
the police the firemen there are other
things economically that need to get
back I mean I was talking to people for
example that food plants and people who
are responsible for communications and
electricity and things like that you're
gonna want to get them back as quickly
as you possibly can and then others who
can still telework at home you might be
able to be as well-functioning just
teleworking at home but there are some
jobs that have been shut down that have
to go beyond teleworking and those are
the ones you want to see how do we get
them back safely and it's gonna be some
very interesting and I think creative
ways of doing that is may one a day when
you can imagine some of that beginning
it is quite possible and you know the
president was asked this specific
question at the press conference today
and he said he will take it you know on
a day-by-day week-by-week basis and at
that point he will consult with the
health people myself and others
physicians and health workers who are on
the task force and then make a decision
and that's why he said appropriately
it's one of the most important if not
the most important decision that he'll
make
do you envision that you know when
people go back hopefully to school and
football games and things like that in
the fall hopefully that we will all be
wearing masks in these places I think
that's quite conceivable you know we
know now that there are that people who
may be asymptomatic who don't know that
they're infected could clearly spread
the infection you know one of the ways
of wearing a physical barrier there
doesn't necessarily have to be the
classic masks that healthcare providers
where is that you must assume that you
help me and I help you I'm assuming that
I might be infected and you assumed that
you might be infected if you wear that
you could decrease it's not gonna be a
hundred percent by any means but you
certainly could decrease the likelihood
that there would be spread so I do see
the fact that wearing a mask in
situations where you can't feasibly and
do your function and your job stay six
would say six feet from someone that a
mask might be an important tool that we
use yeah have you seen this this grocery
store animation and the joggers
animation where someone sneezes and we
can start putting these up on the on the
screen for people at home to see you
know sneeze is in one aisle and it's
it's traveling across you know one aisle
for sure and then the next one and even
into the one after that and then people
jogging and sneezing and spray coming
back on them I know you're a runner I am
too
and when you're out there you know these
are the things that concern everybody
are these logical models what I mean
animations do they make sense to you you
know I did not see them but they would
describe to me accurately enough that
I'm sure that I know exactly what was on
the model you know there was there was a
study that someone asked me a question
at the press conference that when you
sneeze that you can get project out you
know twenty feet or more you know that's
one of the reasons why you save it if
possible you know if you yeah if you
sneeze sneeze into your into your elbow
or wear a mask and if you're sick you
shouldn't be out you should be home
but but you know and when you're jogging
are you gonna try to stay cat you know
not run right behind someone for that
reason you know run behind run next to I
mean I'm again I'd have to take a look
at that video which I have not seen but
all right I want to put up one of our
viewer questions and this first one it
actually comes from one of our
contributors Tammy Bruce I had Fox News
she says until we have a vaccine I
should point out that she's talking
about the immunity certificate the idea
that you might carry something with you
that says yes I've been tested and I'm
immune
she says until we have a vaccine how
does that not incentivize getting the
virus while punishing those who stayed
healthy and can't get one of these
certificates doctor no no I mean that's
that's sort of a false narrative there I
mean I can't imagine someone would want
to get the virus when you know what the
virus can do you get the virus you can
if you haven't had it if you haven't had
it that you would not be able to get one
of those cards and go about your life
you know I don't think that it's gonna
turn out quite frankly I mean there's
been a lot of talk about these
certificates of immunity you know I
think until we get enough testing out
there to get a real feel for the
penetrance of this infection in society
it might be some surprises about that
because there is we don't know a certain
fact fact that we're not sure of is what
percentage of people who are infected
are those who are completely
asymptomatic I mean all their people
who've been infected clear the virus
never knew they were infected never knew
they was sick is that 10% 20% 50% we
don't know that yet when we get antibody
testing that we could do Sarah
surveillances of representative sections
of the population then we'll have a
better a better feel for that but until
then we don't know all right here's this
from Priscilla she says is there any
data out there comparing countries who
took the herd immunity route over social
distancing and is there a big difference
in outcomes I mean for one thing you can
look at a place like Japan which did not
do sort of the kind of social distancing
and mitigation that we did they've only
had 85 deaths in the whole country of
Japan yeah well you know you've got to
be careful when you compare countries
different sizes different borders and
things like that different you know
infusions from outside there's a really
good example that I think answers your
question the UK had decided they were
going to do the let it rip let's get
hurt immunity they did that for a few
weeks and said oops mistake we better
start hunkering down and do physical
separation all right before I let you go
one last question in all the work that
you've done in past with past epidemics
whether it's Ebola or SARS or even HIV
did the models where they you know did
they have the kind of gap that we're
seeing in this one I mean when you were
doing those models did they did they
fail the way this one is in terms of a
33 percent swing in one week have you
ever seen that before yeah yeah and
that's the reason why we're all due
respect to my modeling colleagues I'm
not a modeler they may get upset with me
but I've been what it's been more often
wrong than correct I must say sorry but
it's the truth
I mean if you look at the modeling what
it projected for Ebola it it was way off
it was way off so is it wrong to make
policy based on these models I guess is
the last question no well we get back to
my response to your question before the
policy wasn't made purely on the model
the policy was made on our understanding
of what the virus was doing and could do
you just needed to look at look at China
that's all you needed to do and see what
happened in China and you don't need a
model you know you're dealing with a
really serious problem yeah dr. Anthony
Fauci thank you so much for taking some
of our viewer questions and - well it's
great to be with you tonight
thank you so much sir good to be with
you